wir gehen mit ihnen gemeinsam durch die
krise und genau zu dem thema begrüßen
wir jetzt unseren chefredakteur johannes
boie im studio schönen guten morgen
johannes guten morgen die angst wächst
jeden tag gibt es neue meldungen und wir
haben natürlich auch angst dass der
winter uns wirklich kalte wohnzimmer
zurück lässt was forderst du ganz
konkret von der politik was muss jetzt
getan werden ja du hast recht es sieht
leider tatsächlicher düster aus mehrere
spitzenpolitiker haben das auch schon
eingeräumt bis hin zum kanzler und wir
sind zum ersten mal seit dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs in der lage in der
wirklich deutsche sorge haben müssen
dass ihre wohnung nicht beheizen können
das ist absolut dramatisch
ich glaube es ist ganz ganz wichtig dass
die politik nicht geschlossen den urlaub
fährt sondern handelt dass sie wirklich
den fokus jetzt auf diese themen gelegt
und wegkommt von randthemen die ja in
den letzten wochen viel gesprochen
besprochen worden sind stichwort wie oft
kann ich mein geschlecht beim standesamt
ändern lassen das betrifft nur in sehr
kleinen teil der bevölkerung jetzt geht
es um alle dementsprechend gross muss
der fokus sein ich glaube atomkraftwerke
sollten länger laufen sollte überprüft
werden ob atomkraftwerke die bereits
abgeschaltet sind wieder ans laufen
gebracht werden können da höre ich aus
der politik immer nur geht nicht geht
nicht während ich aber sehe dass
europäische nachbarn atomkraftwerke
bauen ich glaube wir müssen mit den lng
terminals schneller werden und wir
müssen auch mit den erneuerbaren
schneller werden aber wir müssen die
erneuerbaren auch dort auf den prüfstand
stellen wo wir sehen sie bringen
eigentlich nicht das was sie bringen
müssten das einer sehr die
rohstoffknappheit und aber wir ganz
konkret befürchten ja einfach dass es
für unsere portmann ist es irgendwann
wirklich wirklich eng wird und die sorge
ist sehr berechtigt viele fürchten da
jetzt auch einen sozialen abstieg was
kann da die politik tun was muss sie tun
die sorge ist in der tat berechtigt es
gibt charts die zeigen wie der
strompreis in den nächsten monaten und
jahren nach oben schnellen wird strom
darf natürlich in deutschland niemals
ein luxusprodukt werden das muss man
sagen hat auch einfach die regierung von
angela merkel vollkommen versiebt die
einerseits die abhängigkeit zu putin
erhöht hat die andere seite gleichzeitig
auch noch den atomausstieg durchgedrückt
hat dass es vollkommen irre ist damals
auch immer von uns kritisiert worden
wollte aber niemand in der politik dass
die preise jetzt nicht nach oben gehen
hängt ganz stark mit der verfügbaren
menge der energie zusammen und deswegen
sind es genau die maßnahmen auf die ich
gerade hingewiesen habe die jetzt
erfolgen müssen denn je mehr vorhanden
ist desto geringer bleibt der preis
kanzler scholz sagt wir müssen
zusammenhalten uns gegenseitig
unterhaken uns gegenseitig helfen aber
wenn wir mal ehrlich sind wird man davon
nicht satt und gewärmt auch nur ja nicht
wirklich so wie es und sind das stimmt
und deswegen würde ich mir wünschen dass
ganz so scholz auch mal noch mit noch
konkreten vorschlägen kommt was er jetzt
eigentlich zu tun gedenkt aber ich finde
auch das was er da gesagt hat ist nicht
falsch wir müssen jetzt schon auch
darauf achten dass die gesellschaft
nicht auseinanderfällt dass wir
zusammenhalten dass wir zusammenstehen
natürlich nicht mit denen die uns die
misere eingebrockt haben nicht mit den
mächtigen mit dem politikerinnen und
politikern den ich schnell genug handeln
mit den energie chefs die vielleicht
jetzt auch noch marvin einstreichen wie
es bei den großen ölkonzernen der fall
war ja viele können sich den sprit nicht
mehr leisten und die hasen und gewinne
wie nie zuvor wie lange wie seit langem
nicht mehr mit denen stehen wir nicht
zusammen die kritisieren wer hat aber
dass die bevölkerung auch sagen muss
kommen wir helfen jetzt einander wir
lassen uns nicht teilen wir driften
nicht in die extreme ab das ist richtig
und das ist auch wichtig es hat mir
corona krise zwei jahre lang jetzt der
ukraine krieg die menschen sind so was
von gebäuden sie sind fertig sie können
nicht mehr man hat das gefühl das ganze
hört überhaupt nicht mehr auf ein
zeitalter das ja völlig verrückt spielt
wie können wir da wie können wir als
gesellschaft schaffen nicht auseinander
zu brechen ja wir sind tatsächlich in
ein neues zeitalter eingetreten das
merkt man ganz stark in den 90ern noch
wurde spekuliert vom sogenannten ende
der geschichte also es würde jetzt gar
nicht mehr weitergehen man hätte den
idealzustand erreicht ist liebe jetzt
alles so wie es derzeit ist oder wie es
damals war das hat sich natürlich als
vollkommen falsch erwiesen es kommt
jetzt krise nach krise das gab es schon
mal zu beginn eines jahrhunderts und ich
kann nur allen empfehlen die sich davon
einschüchtern lassen die angst haben die
sorge haben dass man das gegenseitig
ernst nimmt sich gegenseitig unterstützt
dem freundeskreis im familienkreis dass
man sich aber auch daran erinnert wie
viel die menschheit seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg geschafft hat es ist ja
eigentlich vieles immer besser geworden
während vor vielen jahren noch viel mehr
leute nicht lesen konnten auf der welt
hunger hatten auf der welt in bitterster
armut gelebt haben sind diese phänomene
ja weitgehend verschwunden nicht überall
aber doch ganz dramatisch zurück
gedrängt worden das ist eine folge des
kapitalismus das eine folge der
marktwirtschaft der freiheit der
demokratie werte für die wir einstehen
jetzt müssen wir eben kämpfen gerade
auch gegen russland ja dass die wir
diese werte behalten und dann werden
auch sicher wieder ruhigere zeiten
kommen obendrein wird uns auch die
technologie helfen die in den letzten
jahren entwickelt worden ist da gibt es
tolle ansätze es gibt neu zum beispiel
auch neuere kleinere atomkraftwerke mit
denen wir wirklich gegen die
energiekrise vorgehen können da ist es
gibt eben auch wichtig dass wir
technologie offen sind und solche dinge
in deutschland wirklich auch haben
wollen klingt so versichert das ist
positiv vielen dank an bild
chefredakteur johannes b ich danke euch